[Music]
Google I think is a revolutionary data
set I call digital truth serum because
people are so honest to it and they
confess things that they might not
confess to anybody else to that little
white box on a search engine
Facebook is different a facebook is
digital brag to my friends about how
good my life is serum where people say
people try to make themselves look good
on Facebook so if you compare two
magazines the Atlantic Monthly and the
National Enquirer the Atlantic Monthly
is kind of an intellectual highbrow
magazine poetry and philosophy and
political theory and the National
Enquirer is a lowbrow trashy magazine
celebrity gossip and rumors and stuff
like that and on average the National
Enquirer sells more copies than the
Atlantic Monthly but on Facebook the
Atlantic Monthly is 45 times more
popular than the National Enquirer
because everybody wants their friends to
think they're reading the Atlantic
Monthly they don't want their friends to
think they're reading the National
Enquirer which makes them seem less
impressive and people exaggerate their
financial situation a circus circus a
budget hotel in Las Vegas holds about
the same number of people as the
Bellagio a luxurious hotel in Vegas but
people are about three times more likely
to check into the Bellagio than the
circus circus so I think on Facebook you
get bombarded with these images all my
friends are staying in the Bellagio well
you know about the same number of them
are staying at Circus Circus they may
just not be posting that on Facebook and
I think it's interesting to compare
these two sources Facebook and Google
Facebook where you're showing off to
your friends Google where you're just
getting in for me to information you
need so one of the comparisons I talk
about in the book is the ways people
describe their husband's on the -
sources the top ways people complete the
phrase my husband is on Facebook is my
husband is the best my best friend
amazing so cute and awesome
and on Google the top waves people
describe their husband my husband is
also one of them is awesome so that
checks out but the other ones are a jerk
gay so mean and annoying
so it's it you know so that's kind of
the difference between what people are
saying when they're trying to impress
their friends and what people are saying
when they're trying to get information
and maybe being I think more honest
Alcoholics Anonymous has this phrase
don't compare your insides to other
people's outsides and I think the 21st
century Big Data version of that would
be don't compare your google searches to
other people's facebook posts
[Music]